real data is often quite messy
there are many possible issues with real
data sets such as bad formatting
trailing spaces duplicates empty rows
synonyms of different abbreviations
difference in scales
inconsistency in description skewed
distributions and outliers
and missing values each of these issues
can cause problems in data analysis
and deserves attention in exploratory
data analysis
there's substantial evidence that data
errors are widespread
in clinical research the error rates are
reported to be between 2.3 percent to
26.9 percent
sometimes a seemingly minor mistake can
cause serious consequences
in 1999 nasa lost a 125 million
mars orbiter because an engineering team
failed to convert measurements from
english to metric units
data exploration is often the first step
in data analysis
it involves summarizing and realizing
the data set
it should be done before any modeling
work
in addition to the detrimental
consequences of data errors as mentioned
before
massive data can also cause modern
issues
as an example a modern approach can fail
if it encounters a long numerical value
for a numerical variable
this is a case for the common yield
regression analysis
also analysis done on massive data can
suffer from the commonly known effect of
garbage in
garbage out in other words data analysis
done on faulty data can often be
misleading
data exploration serves several purposes
first it helps gain intuition about the
data
sometimes this is called data
understanding
such intuition can be quite useful in
subsequent data analysis
and they may even dictate an appropriate
choice of modeling techniques or tools
second it helps conduct sanity checks on
the data to ensure that a data looks
reasonable
in the right format and on the right
scale
third it helps find out whether there
are missing values outliers
finally it is common to summarize the
data in data exploration
these includes both the numeric summary
and data exploration
how should we perform data exploration
the simplest way is to manually review
the data
for those of you who have experienced
working with spreadsheets
you may have manually reviewed data in
the past
however manually reviewing data is labor
intensive and not feasible
even an excel spreadsheet can have as
many 1 million rows
there are several ways to explore large
data sets
the first is to examine samples of data
by working on samples of data we can
directly interact with the raw data even
for large data sets
which can greatly help us to gain some
sense on the data
in the end however we need to summarize
the data either using numerical summary
or data validation
you